Susi's in Utah hi Susie how are you I'm
doing well how about yourself
better than I deserve what's up well my
husband and I went through a few and it
changed our lives so thank you for that
but it's been almost three years now
we're not quite on the same page he
seems to be somewhat content with being
in debt whereas I am like gizelle
intense and it's caused some friction
between us
he said that dreaming big is covetous
and I don't have I guess it depends on
your reasoning personally I want to
enjoy it but I also want to be an
outrageous Giver
I just don't know what to say to him
about that I think he's using a toxic
twist on a Bible verse to not address
this issue in other words that's a bunch
of crap dreaming big is covetousness is
garbage that's just not true okay now
can it be covetousness yeah I can be but
I mean I mean God God said if we being
evil know how to give our children good
give so much more so our Father in
heaven and you know God is not mad at
you when you prosper
it does not automatically mean you
worship money when you prosper as a
matter of fact you can be poor and
worship money and so that's it's a state
of mind it's an attitude it's the
position of money in your spiritual life
is it your God that makes it
covetousness it's not an amount and it's
not right and it's not having ambition
and trying to do better and to serve and
to be you know and to be paid for
serving so he said that he he quoted the
scripture it is easier for a camel to go
through the eye of the needle than a
rich man to enter heaven and he's using
this reasoning to say that he doesn't
want to be rich whereas I'm too late too
late what's your household income just
over thirty nine thousand a year if you
make over thirty four thousand dollars a
year you're in the top 1% of income
earners in the world
you're going to hell that is a very good
point you're going to hell no question
about it you're safe if your salvation
is based on how much money you have your
Jesus didn't die on the cross and his
blood was of no avail
so you're that's heresy that's heresy
yeah to say that Jesus's blood and the
price he paid on the cross is not strong
enough to overcome the fact that you
gained wealth that is not what that
scripture is saying that you lose your
salvation due to well I think he just is
worried that if he becomes wealthy by
America standards that it would be that
much harder to get into heaven
yeah he's got a really weird view of
grace and a really broken theology okay
cuz hey you know last I checked
murderers prostitutes drug dealers can
all get into heaven by accepting Jesus
that's the grace I read right
yeah yeah and even toxic Christian
people can get into heaven if they love
Jesus that's the grace and so you don't
get to earn your way in that's what we
Christians believe yeah other other
religions believe different things but
those of us you and me and him that are
Christians are we you know we believe
Jesus paid the price and when we believe
on that we go to heaven that's what we
believe
yeah and you either believe that or you
don't it doesn't like yeah but you know
you really got to work really hard to
get to heaven I didn't what it was it's
not it's an incomplete grace okay again
that's that's a works theology and that
scripture that is the most misquoted
scripture and and leads people
unintentionally into heresy faster than
anything I've ever seen it's absolutely
ridiculous
and we'll go just one step further I'm
gonna send you a copy of a book called
the legacy journey that I wrote about a
proper biblical view of wealth a
challenge both of you to read it I think
it'll help him if he's actually has an
open mind
I actually am suspect though that he's
just trying to justify the fact that he
doesn't want to work hard and strive
because he free to failure I think
that's what it is and he
trying to wrap it in his Christian lingo
and make it okay to sit on his butt and
I'm really not okay with that that's
kind of embarrassing as a Christian this
is the Dave Ramsey show hey you guys
Rachael Cruz here hope you are enjoying
the Dave Ramsey show and did you know
that I have my very own YouTube channel
yes that's right it's kind of better
than the Dave Ramsey channel don't tell
them I said that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you